you think of people who come to la to
visit
[Music]
and how compton has become
like a thing worldwide you know what i'm
saying i feel like in l.a
like south central content but compton
is like
it's like an iconic hood in the entire
world
everybody gotta count you gotta just you
can go buy a competitive visit bro you
could buy a compton hat in australia
yeah you know what i'm saying like
is that something that do you consider
that to be a gift or a curse because you
know
people might not understand what that
means what all comes with that
it's a it's a curse you know i mean a
gift at the same time because confidence
is so wow
you fit me in haters you know what i
mean and
the politics the gang violence [ __ ] like
that so
you can get caught up in that you've
been saying and you can go to jail you
could be dead you feel me you see [ __ ]
got shot
there's a lot of [ __ ] come with it but
the name is itself comp in the city
from easy now and all that type of stuff
of course man [ __ ]
straight out of compton man i love it i
got to see it so
it's a good thing it's a bad thing bro
let me ask you something when you watch
something like uh
like like the nwa movie right and that's
like a movie that's like
really based around your area and uh
again it's being consumed on a very
large scale
yeah there's white kids in
england watching straight out of
comments yeah real [ __ ] like you feel
good
like you know what like look let's be
honest compton's the most famous area in
l.a yeah
outside of hollywood it's people come to
la
and if they're like yo i want to go to
compton yeah you know what that means
right but you got some people that come
to
los angeles and this depending on who
they are they feel like
they just encounter because they i don't
know you be in hollywood
some people don't want to go to the hood
that's what i wanted to get right there
you know everybody comes to l.a
they go to hollywood they come to the
valley that's all they do
yeah they go to lax to hollywood they do
the little west hollywood [ __ ] they do
melrose
they get back on the freeway they get
back on that 405 they go back to lax to
go home
i feel like they're spitting or
something ain't saying nothing but ain't
seen that
so let's talk about like what like okay
obviously
for anybody watching this way from la
the valley is not la
hell no if you from san fernando if
you're from
encino north hollywood god bless you
that's not l.a
hollywood is not la what is real l.a
well you got to say like like south
central you still saying
like like all up and down
[ __ ] maine and broadway you so i'm
saying yeah i feel like there's just
this big disconnect from people who come
and visit
and be like yeah i was in l.a but like
but were you or were you at like
toku madera in west hollywood like it's
not the same thing
they just say that [ __ ] this to be sent
in the most la you were at was when you
landed at lax
the the the suburb part of it you found
me it's crazy right
but nah [ __ ] in a straight hood bro
they know what's happening